Kiki stash has a clothing warehouse full
of vintage items a little known but
vital part of the entertainment industry
how much stuff have you got in here I've
got about 25
000 pieces of clothing and then plus all
the shoes belts I have everything
jewelry
underwear so I am a vintage vendor to
costumers for TV and film she's not in a
union but the strikes have hit her hard
if there's no writers and no actors and
no new shows there's just no no business
I moved in here in February and so most
of my savings kind of went with the move
and you know I had to
you know refurbish the place and do all
that so I'm pretty much for the business
part I'm living on fumes right now
[Music]
Roman Molino Dunn has composed scores
for many TV and film Productions I write
music for films and television so I get
a movie and they asked me to write a
certain type of music and that's what I
do his work has dried up there's no
writers and there's no actors so the
only projects that are coming in are
documentaries
um I guess some animation reality
television there's a lot of that but
reality television has already moved
away from composers for the most part
they're using stock music like many
other non-union entertainment artists
he's been forced to dip into his savings
if there's no jobs coming in you're
relying on the money from the previous
job and the further that goes into the
future the more uh dismal that seems the
longer it goes on The Closer artists
like stash and Dunn get to leaving their
field altogether luckily it hasn't
gotten to that yet but uh it's very
worrisome to see that this has been
going on for so long
um
if it continues everybody in the
industry will probably have to do as you
suggest and find a job completely
outside of the industry sleepless nights
yeah for sure for sure for sure yeah
absolutely
skills and talents going to waste as the
biggest entertainment strike in decades
drags on Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los
Angeles
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera